hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the essential role of the
molecular identification of
microorganisms in the management of
chronic infections I am Kristin
correction Caleb Lavery's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button as a top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and that offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the cee button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Randall walk on dr. Walcott is the
founder of the Southwest Regional wound
care center in Lubbock Texas the wound
care center specializes in biofilm based
wound care the wound care center offers
state-of-the-art technology with
molecular diagnostics and
state-of-the-art alternative medicine
including customized topical wound gels
he is passionate about healing wounds I
will now turn it over to dr. Walcott for
his presentation
hello I'm dr. Rainey Woolcott and we
want to welcome you to this lab groups
presentation that title is a little bit
intimidating and basically what we're
going to talk about is is how molecular
methods not just DNA methods have
expanded a little bit how the
identification of microorganisms is
becoming more sophisticated and then
were brought it out last time I expose
it was about chronic wounds is this time
we're going to broaden it out to chronic
infections because I think it will
include more of your interests if we do
that Erasmus a long time ago said in the
land of the blind the one-eyed man is
king and basically when you have a
diagnostic test when you can look in and
see the reality of what's happening
whatever you're interested in you have
vision but i would i would caution
around us and i would say it's not just
what you see it's what you understand
and what I hope I can do for you is get
you excited about this stuff where it's
going this truly is a quantum shift in
medicine and the diagnostic tests the
ability to see the microorganisms in in
reality and with measurements with with
scientific certainty is changing the
whole game but before I go into that let
me talk to you about my conflict of
interest I am a part owner in a
laboratory a molecular laboratory and so
I want to brag about it a little bit
NASA came to what our laboratory and
said hey we got this Mars rover the
curiosity and we want to make sure
there's no microbes on that and so we
get our DNA based evaluation there was
no microbes on that and that was cool
and I gives you a lot of credibility
because you know you work with NASA
that's really cool but then we get to
thinking why did they kick her I mean
what's it matter if we send some
bacteria up to Mars well what we found
was that the Martians ever since
were the world's moving they don't like
our bacteria and no the point on this is
what Mark Twain said so long ago he said
back in eighteen hundreds there's lives
there's damn lies and then their
statistics and the more papers i read i
realize that people can work their
statistics to put just about any point
i'm going to try to be as open and
honest on this as we can I know I've got
a position in this I've got a bias but
you know hopefully we can tell you what
settled science with certain and then
what we think and where we think this is
going so it's from a clinical
perspective more than a scientific
perspective so let's start with chronic
infections you know often even on health
care professionals know that what a
chronic infection is versus an acute
infection and basically an acute
infection meal comes quickly you get
three to five to seven days of
antibiotics it clears the infection and
it doesn't come back chronic infections
what they wax and wane you use
antibiotics they get a little bit better
and it ended but they come back they're
chronic and so but if you ask positions
or what is a chronic infection those
sorts of us it's infections bacteria but
you know the host must be broken there
must be poor perfusion or there must be
scar tissue or the immune system is
impaired or something like that that's
that's the way they think of chronic
infections but that's just not true okay
it is a microbial based problem and
that's what we're going to try to
discuss what this slide is just what is
a chronic infection then we're going to
the scope of the problem so way back in
the dark ages seven years ago we were
trying to give information to clinicians
when should they think that they're
dealing with a vile filthy based
infection and what we found was
everything that we found to link to bow
film infection was really a description
of a chronic infection and then last
year
the European infectious disease Society
came out with some guidelines on chronic
infections and what they started their
their guidelines there abstract going
there with was biofilms cause chronic
infections so that's a settled science
okay so this is the best of the best
across the continent of Europe and it's
supported by many microbiologists and
scientists throughout the United States
and basically it's bacteria growing as
mouth films that causes the symptom
complex that we call a chronic infection
whether it's in the sinus whether it's
in the gut whether it's on the heart
valve whether it's in the run or address
if it's on your scanner chronic wounds
so this is this is a really important
again quantum shift in medicine because
now we're now we know what our target is
we have a clear understanding of what is
a chronic infection so what does that
mean well in the scope of medicine every
tissue can suffer a chronic infection
whether it's the sinus whether it's let
me see if I can give you some guidance
here whether it's a sinus or whether
it's cystic fibrosis or COPD whether
it's an infected medical device like a
hip or a knee infected heart valve or us
skin a chronic wound or run that's
bobsville and if you look at how each
discipline has come to treat their
mouths on disease it's usually with
episodic antibiotics neglect like the
patient go and then when the tissue
that's being affected like the sinus or
lungs they they if it's too degraded
then they strip the sinuses they
transplant the lungs and cystic fibrosis
they replace the heart valve they take
out the metal policy system for wound
care providers we cut off the leg now my
point is is these are infections these
are chronic infections we know that
target
and so the better way to tweet that
infection is not to remove body parts
but for us to understand that and that's
why our diagnostic test comes in sure
that which is the Holy Grail and prevent
those lots of them lawsuit heart valve
it just stop the carnage of removing
body parts to make it more personal that
we kind of launched into a different
area of research and that's
atherosclerosis and what we found and
there's a couple articles just in case
you're interested in that is kind of the
mechanism how about them could cause
after rose's and then the second thing
is we were able to go into episodic
lacks harvest against I tube and find
the biofilm structures of clusters and
voids in between so that arrangement a
bacteria cannot be contamination so it's
grown there it's growing these very
dense clusters which we call biofilm so
there is biofilm announces grossest so
now that makes it personal there's not a
one of us out there that doesn't have
that there's not a one of the you
listeners and myself they don't have
periodontal disease and then a third of
us have other chronic infection so this
is a very very wide problem throughout
medicine and that's why the diagnostic
test is so important well I'm a wound
care physician wounds are accessible
epistatic plaques are hard hard mounts
are hard sinuses are hard to get to but
but ones are chronic infections of skin
and skin structures and we can use that
to find out the basic principles of the
host microbe interaction in this kind of
infection and then take those those
principles that we learning wounds and a
climb across the other types of chronic
infections chronic wounds are chronic
infections that is not some science that
that's the ship that steak
place in the wound care community so
this is a patient that was sent to me
from New Mexico and Liz and provider
called me up and said I have this
patient with primarily gangrenosum and
this patient has a necrotic granulation
tissue and again we watched this room
for three or four months and it's just
eaten into her leg and we need something
done but we know we can't debris it
because you don't get very good Irma so
for the for you that they don't know
about pyoderma gangrenosum if you do
breed it it causes a path of good
response a hyper inflammatory response
that causes tissue damage it makes it a
little bit worse so I mean the provider
was correct in that but this is not
granulation tissue this is dead tissue
now what the reason I use this patient
is in illustration is we always talk
about the host being the root are the
cause of the chronic wound diabetes for
circulation repented pressure neuropathy
you know does an impaired immune systems
and the list goes on but it's always
there thinking about the host is the
reason with this lady doesn't happen in
those things she has no autoimmune
diseases or whatever what she has is
bacteria eating down into her flesh so
we did do debridement but we did
debridement but and controlled the
microbes because we had a diagnostic
test and then within about three and a
half months you see the picture to the
right we had granulation tissue and
that's granular you see the little bumps
grains and you see the red color and
stuff so there is no such thing as an
aquatic granulation tissue but at the
end of the day it's not host impairments
that caused this wound it's a chronic
infection the causes of modena so how do
we prove that so let's start at the
beginning I have a defect that through
the skin you got this deep cavity down
into subcutaneous tissue tendon muscle
and stuff like that and
there there's no question that there's
some bacteria in that okay so that
bacteria can do one of three things it
can do something positive like a
commensal it can help that one's heal
well commensals have communication with
the host they have specific cells to
communicate with them specific cytokines
and those mechanisms are more robust
than we ever imagined well the the
muscle tendon bones of cutaneous tissue
doesn't contain those cells doesn't
contain those cytokines so there can
never be commensals at that level in
fact it's a permissive environment and
we get a lot of pushback when we say
well this was caused by staph
epidermidis this one that's what's
infected they said well that's a
commensal I cannot cause infection
that's not true it's not infected when
it's under a host control but when it
gets in that permissive environment
surely it can cause infection of the
other thing the bacteria can do is just
be a contaminant and like this picture
here this is some extracellular matrix
of the host and there's a single
bacteria there and that's what you'd
expect you to expect a few single cell
or little clusters of bacteria spread it
out on the wound bed and they're not
doing any harm and we know what a
contaminant is but then what we do about
this in this one I know we have rods we
have some very small [__] side down here
we have some bigger [__] I in other
places so this is a polymicrobial group
of bacteria you see this these strands
of material that are binding into the
whole surface well that's host proteins
that's fibrinogen that's been
polymerised 25 women and it weaves
itself in it also could set a coat of
sugars around itself so there's a matrix
oh so that is about them it's
polymicrobial it's encased in matrix
material and it's attached to a surface
ok so these this is a way that bacteria
grows
fundamentally different than individual
climb comic bacteria again the
individual planktonic bacteria invade
tissue digest tissue and and have a
slash-and-burn predatory type of
strategy to cause infection and so you
see things like cellulitis or strep
throat or sepsis and a single course of
antibiotics takes care that because
they're not protected what we're talking
about in mild film is this community of
bacteria that's in case in itself
secreted matrix its bounds of the
surface with host proteins that
expresses a vastly different part of its
genome so it's more like a caterpillar
versus a butterfly for the planktonic
bacteria so these are radically
different than the bacteria that you
learned about microbiology causing
infection but the strategy is quite
different also it has to stay it secured
to the surface it did eats this surface
it will be released to the environment
in a world fatal but if it in flames
this surface it can have plasma exudate
that comes out and that's what feeds the
volvo so it's a different infection
strategy and the question is is can
bacteria can this bacteria cause what we
see in a quite one can it cause the womb
to be delayed can it cause the way to
form that fluffy extra day can we see
all the chronic wound behaviors directly
explained by this material that's on the
surface woman well the answer is yes now
this is slide these are slides from mark
the northwestern dr. musto dr. galliano
I got to present right after dr. galeano
and I said can I get those slides
because he was using a term called
biofilm way back in 2008 and basically
what he was showing what is in there
rabbit ear model they could debride
these little punched out wounds
and in an impaired circulation to the
air and then 24 hours later slump would
reform and they didn't call it Slough
what they called it was vile film so
what they did was they looked at this
microscopically they punch out those
little holes and they follow this and on
day three what they found was that this
this granulation gap the base of the
wound that they had punched out before
was was significantly bigger for the
biofilm than for the control how
significantly it was point zero zero
zero one so there's no question that the
presence of this law the presence of the
biofilm delayed the healing of the mouse
works so that's it that's a that's an
important point to take forward so
remembering this work and moving forward
and then looking backwards at cox work
way back in 1800 1860s what we wanted to
do which is a rational way to say that's
the microbiota on the surface alula
polymicrobial mile film that we found on
human words is that the cause of the
human world or is it the host factors
that caused that and so I think this is
a definitive study for that so basically
in cox model you identify the
microorganism in the diseased person you
identify the purified mature culture you
put it into the animal model causing the
same disease and then you recover the
bacteria so that's what we did but
instead of pure culture we took the
biofilm intact and seeded it into the
mouse wound and so on day zero that that
was a homogenized amount of slough that
was harvested from issue
patient from the human world and then
I'm Dave for you can see that in the
mics that were seated that there was
significant sloths that would develop
there was significant exudate there was
significant delay been healing and so we
know we created the thing that leaves in
the mouse model then on day a few days
later we harvested the bacteria the
correlated it back to the bacteria that
was originally taken off the host and
found that we had the same group of
organisms that we started within the
human room there was nearly there was a
very high correlation whereas in
controls the wound field normally there
was there was no significance love no
significant activate and they'll delay
over what they would expect from people
you never mouse so I mean that's good
science that that shows that the
microbiota that's on the surface of the
chronic one the microbiota that that's
involved in any chronic infection is the
cause of that in section we can now the
host factory matter we can augment the
host defenses or we can help the host
but at the end of the day it's the
microbiota that's the main problem in
these chronic infections so I use this
slide to talk about one here but it
applies to all chronic infections and
that's the sad truth chronic infections
are unethical diagnosed ninety-nine
point nine percent of chronic infections
that are that are currently present in
US citizen today they're not diagnosed
because if you get a diagnostic test it
does not help in the treatment of that
disease so in wheelchair we take very
few cultures in in sinus very few
cultures in relative to the amount of
woods I mean
it's it's not like we're treating an
infectious disease it we might check the
exacerbations or something but it's not
the routine diagnostic test in this
chronic infection and so for every
mistake for not knowing Tanner made for
not looking we don't look and it's
because our diagnostic tests on the
clinical culture that most physicians
use don't leave the better outcomes we
get the tests we get a report it usually
tells us one or two things we treat
those one or two things and the wound
doesn't get better the sinus doesn't get
better the heart valve doesn't get
better you know if it fails and it's
because of the limitation of the
diagnostic test a little over two years
ago I was reading a throwaway journal
don't even know the name of it I got
this picture out of it but what the
author said the kind of just rang I only
did it got me passionate about this what
he said was what we couldn't culture all
the bacteria well basically that's
admitting that you can't cultural vector
and each one of us know that we know the
limitations some bacteria grow very
slowly so many different nutrients
anaerobic bacteria needs a different
environment you know it's difficult to
grow bacteria I heard estimates like
ninety-nine percent of bacteria can't be
cultured I've heard estimates the
eighty-five percent can't we cultured
but there's there's a large group of
bacteria they can I want you to look at
that picture because that is what
conquer was fighting way back when he
started what he found with he grew
things on potatoes and other media he
found that he obtained polymicrobial
communities and and he made the decision
then that no it's just a single organism
and I need a pure culture of that single
thing that's causing the disease okay
and we're locked into that today and
that was a
that was put into microbiology into
clinical medicine over a hundred years
ago so we want to change that because
biofilm inherently is polymicrobial it's
multiple different species that reside
in a single community much like these
different community issues beyond the
plate so by its very origins that the
petri dish the longer the new prints
were used put a bias into finding a
single organism and the nutrients that
we put on the biases we want to find
gram-positive aerobic bacteria so guess
what we kind of our culture we find that
and we can see that in this diagram here
this down is getting a little bit oldest
from 2003 but this is what culture show
and what you're seeing is and if you
break into that thirty percent what this
is showing is about sixty to sixty-five
percent of the bacteria that were
identified in 1400 samples we're
gram-positive aerobic bacteria there's
no anaerobes in there pseudomonas leave
underrepresented there's very few gram
negatives so you know that's the bias of
the culture that that is not the reality
of the microbes on the room that's
that's what we will get at so we realize
that and so we went out the litter joins
it you know how can we identify what
what microorganisms are present in the
world and we can do it with great
sensitivity and great specificity and
that's when the human microbiome project
data came out now here are those
statistics that I was talking about now
you can prove anything with those but
what the bottom line of what the human
Michael Michael Ryan project came up
with was 16 s can can help us identify
what bacteria is there and it can give
us a relative quantification of which
one's there now the whole genomics irv
aids probably show a little bit better
in this data down here
but that's a lot more expensive to do
with our 16 s so but now that that bad
is coming along and now with newer
methodologies that the master the mass
spec proteomics the the different and
deeper methods for sequencing the hope
you're not more dad is coming online to
not only identify my fourth message but
identify resistant mobile genetic
resistance factors and also to help us
with quantitative information so it's
becoming it's evolving it's getting
cheaper and it's giving us more and more
information as we go along I won't call
myself out as an expert in my killer
methods I mean I'm the guy that uses it
i'm trying to get context for how
important this is and how how
revolutionary how this can move the ball
in managing chronic infections one of
the old old technologies I mean this
must be 30 years old is it 35 is
real-time pcr and the thing about
real-time pcr is if you go to the
inflection points you can find the CT
number and you run some normative data
on your plate you can work backwards
based on anonymity really attracted to a
no ballpark figure of how many
individual of microbial cells are
present in that sample so you basically
could say that you can get one of those
exponential numbers of position up so
much so we can take into the filter tend
to the fourth the fifth of such and such
so it gives you an idea of how much
bacteria you have in your sample it
varies with the sampling methods it
varies with there's a heterogeneity in
chronic infection now where the bacteria
is present but in in the end it gives
you a pretty good measure how much
bacteria are dealing with and we call
that bacterial load in fact if that goes
significantly offer it goes
significantly down you kind of have a
feel for how effective your treatment is
so on we like real-time pcr mainly for
the universal 16 years but also it can
tell us what bacteria is there would and
you know if I know that mercy is present
if I know that pseudomonas is present if
I know that thank you my own existence
is present I can I can alter my Imperial
Air be on day one instead of your week
later two weeks later so it's a PCR has
the advantage of quick a rapid
turnaround and it can tell us about
specific target and it has the absolute
quantitative ability to kill us in how
much is there we're a sequencing is more
relative the quantification there is it
says well it's three percent this and
twenty percent that but you don't know
what the total is and but still it tells
you what your dominant bug is so we've
looked at three thousand different
wounds this new data and what we found
was that is indeed present and it it's
the big dog but my number four we have a
neural then down here we have proprio no
bacterium and then kept in a fellas so
so anaerobic species are breaking into
our top ten and yet we've never been
able to culture with clinical cultures
of these bacteria and we've never really
been able to manage them clinically we
can't see if we've impacted them in any
way now we have a diagnostic tested
those okay so and then the other thing
is these are polymicrobial but if we
usually treat at a genus level and so
what we did was we resolved all these
different species for Staphylococcus
into a a single group and what we found
was it over 62 week for some time there
is a staff species but then
I mean that it's a major thing but what
what was quite interesting was running
back jeremy became number two now and
that's a grandpa's suit micro
pseudomonas still kept its position but
now we've got four different androids
that comes to the top and there in
twenty five percent of wounds pretty
much respectively so animal dress huge
card of these chronic infections now
we're looking at anthro sporadic flag
we're looking at sciences we're looking
at heart valves and the antelopes are
there so they're going to be a much
bigger part of medicine that we have
ever expected and now we have a tool
that will actually identify those things
so so this is critical and for each
different chronic infection this
information is being obtained so let's
look at culture versus a molecular
methods and what we found in 50
consecutive patients where we sent a
sample to a university laboratory within
a sample to a molecular diagnostic
laboratory we kept a sample for
refereeing what we found was and if we
look at cultures we found 97 different
organisms cultured 5 was the most number
of species that were identified in any
single sample well if we look at the
molecular compared to that of molecular
failed to identify seven of the bacteria
that were in that we said that to the
refereeing laboratory and what we found
was they were never in there those were
contaminants or were picked up during
the plating and culturing methods we
also found that about seventeen percent
or minor things these are things that
are two to three orders of magnitude
less than the rest of the bacteria
within the wound or within the sample so
that that goes to the growth bias of
cultures now when we look at
the citizens when we look at molecular
methods and we exclude anaerobic
bacteria just apples to apples aerobic
what we find is we find five times as
much bacteria we find way more dominant
bacteria than culture found and even if
we take off all the minor bacteria or
still it 250 important species that need
to be treated so basically it's not the
cultures are wrong they're just
incomplete and they're so incomplete
they don't solve our diagnostic problem
this is why there has to be a ship from
culture to molecular the resistance to
taking up molecular diagnostics is
basically this chart right here when the
doctor gets back that there's seven
eight twelve different significant
microorganisms in the road what do you
do with that you know how do you treat
that and that's for another lecture
which is real briefly if you can
collapse those different geniuses end it
into antibiotic treatment groups usually
you can come up with one or two three
antibiotics that will cover the entire
community and so you're not treating one
group and allowing another group to grow
up and take over the space so it's not
as difficult as it you know it's
intimidating the first but it really
gets to be quite easy all right so
that's our hope and change you know it's
there's there's clinical cultures
they've been present for over 100 years
they're geared towards iconic
single-cell organisms they're great
they're they're geared towards grandpas
of Arabic bacteria and then on the right
we have bioinformatics that can take the
information from whatever platform you
want to look at I mean there's a number
of sequencing platforms from pacbio to
Ion Torrent illuminage yeah you name it
and they're different and they build
slightly different results but but are
more accurate than any culture and
results and the computers can sort out
some of the
differences but in the end of the day
that the the molecular methods give us
data that's actual that changes and and
drastically improves the outcome of
management of chronic infections so
that's the guts of this lecture right
here I can't go into the technology the
different platforms because of time and
because that's not what I do but for the
remainder of this life I just want to
show you how it makes a difference so
the this slide is always to remind me we
always think the management of chronic
infections this guy's trying to study
the problem but in the end what he
really needs to do is just use the brush
and so debridement physically breaking
up the the surface accumulation of these
bacteria that are housed inside this
protective coating housed inside these
host proteins once we do that now they
have to reconstitute that and while
they're trying to reconstitute do that
our treating agents will be more
effective so debridement is the main
treatment for any chronic infections now
wounds they're accessible and that makes
it very easy to us so what I would tell
you is this isn't brain surgery well
sometimes a days okay but basically if
something's necrotic if it's dead it has
to go it's no longer helping the patient
so what we do is we go in and we remove
any dead revitalize tissue that's that's
bone that's exposed there we get rid of
this Slough this love is not an oculus
that is the infection it's accreted to
the surface of the wood and prevents the
healing of the world and this gentleman
did go on to heal but it was with
aggressive debridement that change that
there's one problem with the bereavement
and the problem i'll demonstrate with
with a clip because it is exactly what
happens on a chronic wound so we'll show
you slide number 20 now and it's a video
so if we can play the video of slide
number 20 hasta la vista baby
[Music]
now that's not sort of like what
debridement is that is exactly what
debridement is so basically we break up
when removed ninety-nine point nine
percent of the bacterial cells but we
leave those fragments those fragments re
attached to the surface of the infection
site they grow they coalesce and within
24 hours they go up they put that skin
around themselves and then they're
impervious to our treating agents our
antibiotics our file signs that we put
on there so that's a good demonstration
that's a good take on remember that
that's a good hook to remember just
exactly the way biomax when we try to
treat it so the next video is how we get
around that so once we'd agreed what
we're doing is we're putting on multiple
different things at the same time so
that as that as that tries to coalesce
and on that mouth filled again we're
killing the individual cells that do
that so we're going to show you video
for number 21 now this is dr. Randy
Walcott and this is a video under
bereavement debridement is a
foundational principle about zone-based
wound care and that debridement allows
all our other treatment strategies to be
so much more successful we want to first
alter the anatomy of the wound what that
means is we want to remove any surfaces
that touch that means removing tunnels
and tracks and undermining because
surface is a touch favor the biofilm
over the host this will open up surfaces
that have degraded tissue we want to
remove anything that's soft and friable
anything that's hard and cannot support
angiogenesis it's hard to remove too
much tissue so be aggressive next we
want to manage the surface now this can
be done with a curette or other
instruments ultrasound negative pressure
therapy maggots but all of them have the
goal of trying to degrade the biofilm
and disrupt its structure this forces
the biofilm to reconstitute itself
and while it's regrowing it's vulnerable
to our other treatments now look what
we've accomplished this is a healing
womb clearly there's some new
angiogenesis as evidenced by the texture
there's contraction the wound edges and
you can see that there's material that's
moved up around the great oh this is
connective tissue and fragments of bone
and they did not grow there what's
happened is we've suppressed the biofilm
to a point where host healing mechanisms
such as neutrophils macrophages model
fibroblasts can do their job they can
lyse the tissue and move it up to the
top now a week later we come back and
there's another fragment of bone there's
other tissue and that's because there's
an intact host healing mechanism
bacteria possess multiple molecular
mechanisms to suppress wound healing
when we suppress the one biofilm
adequately then host healing Ria's the
neutrophils of fibroblast endothelial
cells start working again so now we have
a wound bed with suppressed biofilm and
active host healing parameters this is a
well-prepared wound bed that's now ready
for cell-based therapy to get full
enclosure
welcome back so that is biome basement
here in a nutshell so what we'll do is
there we go so just want to show good
cases real quick to wrap up and what
this means okay so anywhere in the
country right now you go into to the ER
you see your Datak surgeon somebody has
a charcoal but with osteo that's modern
Matic amputation by curing the chronic
infection called the chronic wound and
called the osteomyelitis the patient
heals up in 16 weeks and goes on and
keeps his foot and the durability is
just as good as if he'd never had that
one before this is bone intended
infection in a diabetic it was bad this
this patient also was totally needed an
amputation but within 12 weeks you know
it feels up because we manage the
chronic infection here's a non-healing
surgical wound and this this he'll have
been 17 weeks again tendon deep
structures were involved and by managing
the chronic infection was healed all
these patients were being seen at the
same time here we had about 15 of these
kind of cases going on concurrently so
it's common and the outcomes of being
able to diagnose what the microbiota is
formulate treatment aight treating
agents that directly attack those
microbes that we identified lead to this
kind of behavior and so I want to
illustrate that with this one last
patient because this is such a good
story The Ellen is not this guy's name
this is a concrete worker got some
concrete on the top of this footage he's
a type 1 diabetic from early childhood
very narrow pathak he gets a sack full
of cost much like that guy's foot that
we saw earlier and he's got two areas of
osteomyelitis
they drain the blood they see the bone
is infected and somewhat squishy and so
they wake him up and they say your life
has to come off well he's a construction
worker and Hughes is constructed
language and says no thank you he means
am a comes to our clinic we treat him
that day we do that biofilm base won't
care we do the debridement we get our
molecular our DNA based microbial
diagnostics we start him on empiric
multiple concurrent different agents
empirically and he started getting
better about two to three days later the
orthopedic doctor calls me and he says
this guy's going to die and and his
death is on your head and you know i'm
going to make life miserable for you and
i'm going to get your lives and settle i
think even use a lot of that
construction language but at the end of
the day we knew that that was a chronic
infection and a patient that had good
preciation of this blood so I mean I'm
less not that worried about it kind of
worried about it when there's there's
threats involved but four weeks later it
looks like that and that's what we're
talking about if you can if a chronic
world is caused if a chronic infection
is caused by battlefield then if you
collapse the bowel film why wouldn't
there going to act like an acute loop so
this is 4 weeks later let's look at the
dates here 729 I'm 28.6 not quite a
month and there there's a magnificent
and not appeal to shield like an acute
one because that's the Holy Grail if you
can convert a chronic wound to an acute
wound it should feel like an acute one
then that four weeks later it's almost
table let him go back to work at eight
weeks and we released him at 12 weeks
and and that is what we're talking about
it that is what is the outcomes can
change based on denied the ability to
diagnose and adequately treat the cause
of of the chronic room which is the mic
so here's the valve film surprise there
are two ways of bacterial infec there's
the planktonic the cause of acute
infection and then there's the biofilm
that causes chronic infections and
chronic infections it caused more deaths
than them cancer and heart disease
combined so it's a big deal diagnose and
treat most one cares done by trial and
error and what we're talking about is
with a diagnostic test to be able to
target the cause of the chronic wound we
can treat effectively and get better
outcomes so remember this chronic
infections require required you cannot
the clinical cultures sales so they
require molecular analytic methods
whether that's DNA base where that's
protein babes whatever tools you're
using we will identify microbes and
their their activities with molecular
methods going forward and not with the
hundred year old technologies the reason
for that is because Bob there's probably
microbial it's viable but it's not
comfortable it does not culture in under
routine conditions and then there's so
many different bacteria there that
require different growth requirements
that a single clinical culture is not
practical you'd have to do a ton of them
and you would know which ones which
media in which environments to choose so
because of that the and the ability to
quantitate molecular methods will take
over so that's my own surprise the nurse
that taught me how to do my wound care
she said that about that Slough is like
a bunny in the garden yeah you can take
it off you can leave it but it's not
it's the biofilm it is the chronic
infection it's the cause and we now have
the tool to see what it is and hopefully
now we've provided some context to
understand what that micro god is so
thank you for attention and I welcome
any questions
thank you for that informative
presentation dr. will cause before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window will try
to answer as many questions as we can
and our first question is why do you
won't care specialists have to be bright
chronic wounds doesn't that just make
them bigger well yeah but that is a good
question and a lot of patients have
concern about that I'd say two things
number one when we biopsy words those
biopsy sites where do we go through the
wound or we go across the marginal one
those those pieces that we take out to
send off for pathology or to identify
bacteria she left on a week they come
right back to where the deviations over
the microbiota is so if you take off too
much like a tissue it comes right back
to where the chronic wound was even in
nine-year-old diabetics who go right
back up to the surface in a very brief
period of time so you can't make it
bigger so what I tell patients is is
it's like I'm packing a suitcase the
damage is done the material is there
that is not self anymore it's dead
tissue it's bacteria it's plasma it's
stuff that can never help the wound and
we're not we're not making the defect
bigger we're just on it's like opening
the suitcase and clinging it out it
didn't make the suitcase bigger okay it
just it just opens up the area so know
that the debridement is critical because
it takes away the most important defense
mechanism that the mouth
have so we have to do that and then the
second thing is is if you can't take up
too much because the host will feel if
you go too far it's a look at what the
wound will heal the tissue will hit
right back up to the room so that was
very good question
okay for our next question why is it
that molecular methods for
identification of microorganisms is not
generally used and people still use
clinical cultures I get that question
all the time okay that there's there's
two big barrier well I guess there's the
third barrier the biggest thing is is
most people don't know about it they
don't know how to order the tests they
don't know you know where to go and
stuff like that but if they have access
to molecular tests if they if they get
the results back like I mentioned
earlier in the presentation you get six
seven eight different things that that's
in your chronic infection and then it's
like what I do with that I know my
liable to treat all those things which
one's the passage okay bottom line is we
don't know we do know it's a community
we don't know which constituents of the
the community causes the damage to the
host but we're assuming that they know
they all play a part so we treat them
all it's easier than what we say but
it's really that they get too much
information to be too and it's kind of
overwhelming at first when you're
starting to use it there's there's other
barriers to acceptance the traditions
the familiarities with sensitivities and
stuff like that and molecular does not
currently tell you what the bacteria
sensitive but bow film phenotype
bacteria require anywhere from 250 to a
thousand times um I see that you find
when you played out of planktonic
bacteria so at the end of the day
sensitivities don't really help us out
much in chronic infections but we can't
get past those biases very much very
easily so it's the lack of sensitivities
it's the overwhelming amount of
information that clinicians are
I'm familiar with that kind of it's a
barrier to acceptance but at the end of
the day that's where it's you will be it
just has to molecular more specific it's
more sensitive and it tells us what's
really there and then we have to figure
out what's important but it definitely
improves our outcomes so it the change
will take place but those are important
very ourselves good question any other
questions okay we have another question
what makes biofilm infections so
tolerant to treatments and so difficult
to cure okay so now we're back into my
wheelhouse and I like that I like that a
lot miles of anti bacterial express a
third of their genome different from
planktonic bacteria so it really is a
caterpillar butterfly their radically
different and just that genetic
expression makes them more resistant to
most antibiotics that it's single-cell
form that gene expression would allow to
show that that bacteria but then there's
multiple defenses that the Volvo has it
has the matrix around itself that blocks
diffusion of certain antimicrobials it
has different metabolic states within
the mile film and when something is when
there's no metabolism antibiotics can't
poison the machinery at the machinery is
not working so there's just a lot of
there's bottom defenses there's volatile
gene expression there there's there's a
lot of reasons why antimicrobial stop
working in
in chronic wounds and other chronic
infections but at the end of the day we
can force the bacteria into certain
behaviors into certain phenotypes and
then they're more susceptible to our
treating agents so knowing the target
knowing some of its defenses knowing
some of the way it behaves gives us that
gives us a significant advantage in
suppressing it and allowing the host to
heal so that that was a good question
any others yes we have time for one more
question today how does biofilm keep
chronic wounds from healing okay so and
let's just take this out to all chronic
infections so the bacteria sticks to it
finds its way to a barrier an epithelial
barrier whether that's in with sinus
whether it's in the endothelial cells on
the heart valve for Africa roses in the
a1 in other places whether it's Crohn's
disease in the gut the bacteria finds
its way through the epithelium and
attaches to the host extracellular
matrix if it can put it's the coating
around itself white blood cells can't
penetrate and antibodies can't penetrate
and now it's walled off from host
immunity the way it feeds itself is it
inflames the surface but what we found
and here's the critical part is that
through type 3 secretion systems type
for secretion system type 6 it puts
small molecules into our Co cells or
they smoke they are called effector
proteins or these small molecules can be
diffused out into the tissue and they
commandeer are those those small
proteins will
blah kpop drama crabs ways so they'll
commandeer protein destruction that
through blocking ubiquitylation though
they get in and they gum up the cellular
machinery of the cells and that makes
the cell senescence so when we look at
cells on Beluga they can't migrate they
can't manufacture they can't my toes
that they're there live but they can't
do what cells normally do and when we
look further we find that their pathways
have been poisoned and that poisoning
comes from the problem but sets on the
surface so the way that it blocks
healing is through multiple different
molecular mechanisms that haven't
probably been defined and we don't
really have countermeasures for right
now but both of them it has very
specific tools that keep the wound from
healing again we have a good tool where
we can identify who the constituents are
and then we can use known tried-and-true
methods to kill those individual
constituents and then that takes that
problem away so but wow film has ways to
block healing that have not been fully
elucidated but are very sophisticated
multi-tier multifunctional and so lots
of targets air for treatment for any of
the guys that are you know know how long
and though a research and stuff this is
a huge area that can be exploited for
the management of chronic infections so
good question
that's all the time we have for today I
would like to once again thank dr.
Walcott for his presentation do you have
any final comments I really appreciate
the opportunity I think this is a war
area especially in my medical
microbiology and anybody that's
interested in this just look at some
articles I put my email up at the front
I usually answer those and you know just
be happy to help anybody get started
necessary thank you very much dr. Mullen
today's webcast will be mailed available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2017 you will receive an email from
lavage alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye